und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend in allen an einem tag an dem
sich der streit um deutschlands mobile
zukunft am frankfurter messegelände
zeigt dort ist seit heute die
internationale automobilausstellung fürs
publikum geöffnet vor der tür
protestieren die die sich unsere städte
zu fuß und mit dem fahrrad zurück
erobern wollen eine echte verkehrswende
fordern und zwar sofort die veranstalter
sagen es sind 25.000 drinnen schauen und
staunen die anderen manche wollen die
fortbewegungsart der zukunft erleben
manche einfach nur mehr ps die
veranstalter sagen es sind 60.000 ein
tag an dem man erleben kann wie weit der
weg noch ist in diesem land
peter theißen schon am morgen treffen
sie sich alleine in wiesbaden sind es
mehrere hundert radfahrer die die knapp
50 kilometer strecke nach frankfurt in
angriff nehmen
mehr platz fürs rad fordern sie heute
haben sie ihn ausnahmsweise ganze
autobahnabschnitte rund um frankfurt
gehören ihnen menschen auf dem rad und
zu fuß demonstrieren friedlich aber mit
nachdruck für eine verkehrswende dafür
dass die autos aus den innenstädten und
den wohngebieten verschwinden
dass wir stattdessen diese riesigen
flächen nutzen für öffentlichen raum für
fahrradwege für fußgängerwege und
gleichzeitig
brauchen wir einen kostenlosen pnv ich
bin mutter von hat zweijährigen tochter
und ich möchte dass die zukunft hat
draußen also die forderung nach einer
neuen verkehrspolitik und einer
beschneidung der macht der autokonzerne
doch drinnen auf dem gelände der iaa am
ersten besuchertag großes interesse auch
an den in der kritik stehenden mein sohn
kriegt jetzt dem nächsten smart und also
auch mal im zweitwagen bereich haben wir
schon was gemacht und ich habe aber eine
hohe kilometerleistung und auch ein
dienstwagen und für mich ist eben
spannend kann ich demnächst eben auch
auf elektro fahrzeuge umsteigen
es gibt also die die glauben mit neuer
technik bekomme man die klimaproblematik
schon in den griff und die gemeinen nein
es geht nur mit weniger auto wir wollen
aber auch druck in richtung berlin
ausüben weil das was bisher
bundesminister scheuer vorgelegt hat an
maßnahmen für das klimaschutzprogramm
2030 überhaupt nicht ausreichen
wird sich die politik bewegen viele
demonstranten mit neuer zuversicht und
der protest geht weiter
für morgen hat das aktionsbündnis sand
im getriebe angekündigt die zugänge zur
iaa zu blockieren
jetzt gehen wir zwei jahrhunderte zurück
zu einem der nie einen zweifel daran
hatte wie wichtig das klima für die
menschheit ist und wie sorgsam der
mensch mit seiner umwelt umgehen sollte
wenn alexander von humboldts seinen
geburtstag heute erleben könnte er würde
sich die augen reiben erstmal natürlich
weil er dann 250 geworden wäre und eine
welt sehe in der sich menschen von
fakten abwenden gefühltem zu wenden und
die autorität von wird
wissenschaftlicher vorstellung zu
schwinden scheint es wäre ihm ein gräuel
alexander von humboldt war einer der
immer zu und überall fragen hatte und
deshalb antworten fand die bis heute
wege weisen er war ein
universalgelehrter aber vor allem war
neugierig auf diese welt kein wunder
dass sie heute aus aller welt nach
berlin kommen um ihn zu feiern
im humboldtforum stephan merseburger
indigene aus dem amazonasgebiet sind
gekommen es ist eine zeremonie
sie machen es in berlin so wie zu hause
wenn ein haus neu ist es bekommt eine
art segen eine ganze körperdrehung
gehört zum ritual und farbe im gesicht
der hausherr des humboldt-forums macht
selbstverständlich mit
wenn wir uns darauf einlassen dass das
wirklich ein forum ist für menschen aus
aller welt
dann können wir nur zu hören staunen und
auch dinge neu erfahren und auch uns auf
diese einlassen
alexander von humboldt wandertour
forscher abenteurer umweltaktivist und
universalgelehrter er wollte die gesamte
welt verstehen
seine wohl wichtigste expedition führte
ihn nach lateinamerika pflanzen tiere
chemie physik philosophie alles
interessierte ihn sein werk ist
gigantisch humboldt setzte sich für die
rechte der indigenen bevölkerung ein und
er war ein erklärter gegner der
sklaverei sein vermächtnis ist aktuell
wie eh und je
leider auch angesichts rassistische und
nationalistische ab und ausgrenzung
lateinamerikanische künstler haben ihre
sicht auf den welterklärer mitgebracht
wie andere auch brauchte humboldt träger
für gepäck und objekte die auf seinen
reisen sammelte für den humanisten
humboldt aber kam es anders als für
andere nicht infrage selbst getragen zu
werden
mich interessiert der widerstand der
träger es gibt berichte über träger die
sich einfach betrunken haben und da wir
nicht mehr tragen können oder die
einfach aufgehört haben zu tragen oder
die ihren kunden gesagt sie sollten ihr
glück alleine versuchen aus
träger waren teuer und die
machtverhältnisse auch zu zeiten des
kolonialismus komplex eine andere
performance erzählt von den ruderern die
humboldt durch das amazonas gebiet
gebracht haben er wäre ohne die
ortskenntnisse der indigenen
hoffnungslos verloren gewesen heute
befürchten sie ihren lebensraum zu
verlieren
alle staaten und regierungen sollen
unsere art zu leben respektieren und
dafür garantieren so erstrahlte die
ostfassade des humboldt forums am abend
die sternbilder liefern den indigenen
seit jahrhunderten wichtige erkenntnisse
über den jahreszyklus heute ist ihr
leben im einklang mit der natur bedroht
humboldt würde dagegen wohl lautstark
ankämpfen
und er hätte viel zu kämpfen es gibt den
humboldtstrom den humboldt peak in
colorado den pico humboldt in venezuela
wohin man rührt er ist überall zu hause
hat goethe über ihn gesagt halb halb
neid
jetzt kommen die nachrichten deutschland
will künftig jeden vierten
bootsflüchtlinge aufnehmen das kündigte
innenminister seehofer in der
süddeutschen zeitung an
das angebot sei teil der verhandlungen
über einen vorteil mechanismus in europa
bislang müssen asyl suchen nur auf tage
und wochen auf see ausharren bis ich
aufnahmebereite eu-länder finden
für die 84 migranten auf der ocean
viking hat das warten ein ende
sie dürfen auf der ebene italienischen
insel lampedusa an land
der israelische botschafter in
deutschland alaa karoff hat die afg als
eine partei bezeichnet wie verbrechen
des nationalsozialismus verharmlost
antisemitismus sei nicht nur für juden
eine gefahr sondern für die ganze
gesellschaft sagte er der neuen
westfälischen
gestern hatte bundespräsident steinmeier
die afg mit deutlichen worten kritisiert
im spiegel bescheinigte er der partei
indirekt eine antibürgerliche haltung
zwei wochen vor der parlamentswahl in
österreich hat die rechtspopulistische
fpö einen neuen vorsitzenden
ein parteitag wählte norbert hofer in
das amt das er bislang als übergangschef
innehatte der 48 jährige ist damit nun
offiziell nachfolger von heinz christian
strache der im mai zurückgetreten war
auch als vizekanzler
hintergrund war die sogenannte pizza
affäre
in saudi arabien wurden zwei wichtige öl
anlagen mit drohnen angegriffen
eine der größten erdöl
verarbeitungsanlagen der welt und das
zweitgrößte ölfeld des landes an beiden
orten brachen feuer aus die inzwischen
unter kontrolle sein sollen
noch ist unklar ob und wie stark der
ölexport beeinträchtigt ist die attacken
könnten die spannungen in der golfregion
weiter verschärfen denn die
verantwortung übernahmen jemenitische
husse rebellen die von saudi arabiens
erzfeind iran unterstützt werden
er war ein leidenschaftlicher kämpfer
für europa nun ist der ungarische
schriftsteller georgi konrad gestorben
bekannt wurde der holocaust-überlebende
1969 mit seinem debüt-roman der besucher
später war er mehrere jahre lang
präsident der berliner akademie der
künste
immer wieder mahnte er menschenrechte
und grundfreiheiten an auch das brachte
ihm zahlreiche auszeichnungen ein
konrad wurde 86 jahre alt es gibt themen
die verlangen vor allem eins man muss
dranbleiben über die tagesaktuellen
schlagzeilen hinaus wir haben viel über
die brennenden regenwälder im
amazonasgebiet berichtet in den letzten
wochen und die verheerenden auswirkungen
auf unser klima wir berichten weiter
nicht nur über die lage auch über
möglichkeiten sie entscheidend zu
verbessern
christoph bröcker rat ist unser
südamerika korrespondent christoph guten
abend vielleicht am anfang wie ist die
situation jetzt im moment hatte sich
etwas beruhigt
momentan hat sie sich tatsächlich etwas
entspannt das liegt zum einen daran dass
in weiten teilen des waldes jetzt regen
fällt zum einen hat die regierung
zähneknirschend doch dem internationalen
druck etwas nachgegeben und bataillone
des militärs in den wald zum löschen
geschickt die jetzt auch da einiges an
erfolge erzielen können aber natürlich
brennt ist an vielen stellen weiter und
was heißt das für das ganz große bild
damit das ganze dann auch tatsächlich
dauerhaft unter kontrolle kommt wie wäre
das möglich
das ist ziemlich komplex die
hauptursache für die brände sind hier
tatsächlich immobilienspekulation man
muss sich das so vorstellen ein hektar
regenwald kostet je nach region
umgerechnet gerade mal 80 euro wenn ich
arbeite an diesen wald habe kann ich
davon wegen des strengen brasilianischen
waldschutz gesetzes maximal 20 prozent
tatsächlich nutzen
ein hektar abgeholzt oder abgebrannter
regenwald dagegen lässt sich für unter
umständen mehrere tausend euro verkaufen
ich kann also ihre gewinne erzielen wenn
ich einen regenwald abholzen
weiterverkauf und hoffe dass das ganze
nicht auffällt ist ja bei die regierung
da leider nicht sehr streng dass sich
wirklich etwas ändern müssen die
brasilianer zu malen effizienter werden
nicht einfach wenn der boden nichts mehr
hergibt ein weiteres waldstück roden und
dann da eben weitermachen
vorne müssen sie begreifen das ganze
auch den exporten schade denn das image
brasiliens so ruiniert des riester gral
der fall ist und es gibt tatsächlich
einige die das begriffen haben und
umdenken wir haben ein pharma getroffen
der gelernt hat wie man den die umwelt
schützen und gleichzeitig damit mehr
oder zumindest sehr gut geld verdienen
kann und was der mann am amazonas macht
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an mauro
ist grossgrundbesitzer und stolzer
rinder baron in dritter generation vom
rücken seines maltese aus herrscht er
über seine gigantische ranch im
brasilianischen bundesstaat pará am
amazonas und doch ist er anders
ausgeschert aus der herde der
brasilianischen züchter denn er will den
regenwald bewahren
[Musik]
diese mehr davon dass man mehr abholzen
muss um zu wachsen ist blödsinn
stattdessen müssen wir unsere
produktivität erhöhen auf den flächen
die wir bereits haben wie
haifischflossen aus dem meer ragen die
höcker der zewo rinder aus dem hohen
gras das niveau hier extra anpflanzt er
denkt die böden wechselt alle paar tage
die beiden so kann er auf gleicher
fläche viermal so viele rinder ernähren
wie seine kollegen die immer neuen wald
für ihre rinder roden
ich denke dass fehlendes wissen ein
grund ist warum es so schwer ist etwas
daran zu ändern wie wir rinderzucht
betreiben und bequemlichkeit wenn man
sich verbessern will muss man seine
komfortzone verlassen und viele wollen
das nicht
maurer will die anderen züchter
überzeugen und nimmt uns mit zu einem
vortrag in der stadt doch das interesse
hält sich in grenzen
viele kollegen sind skeptisch manche
weniger als verräter
immerhin heute hat sich sogar ein
abgeordneter aus der hauptstadt ins
publikum verirrt die meisten haben mich
angeschaut als wäre ich einem comic heft
in sprung aber der abgeordnete fragte
mich ob ich eine kopie der präsentation
hätte und ich sagte nicht nur dass ich
habe einen hof auf dem ich das alles
umsätze kommen sie doch mal vorbei
zurück auf der farm zeigt mauro erstmal
uns wieder neue bilder entstehen ist er
pflanzt bäume einer schnell wachsenden
sorte deren holz viel geld bringt und
selbst wenn er die in ein paar jahren
gewinnbringend abholzt entsteht hier
ganz nebenbei ein neues stück regenwald
denn im schützenden schatten der bäume
bereitet sich nach und nach natürlicher
wald aus bis dahin pflanzt mauro hier
eine besonders nahrhafte gras sorte für
seine rinder alles dient dem profit und
bewahrt gleichzeitig die biologische
vielfalt des amazonas für mauro ein
gütesiegel seines produktes niemand auf
der welt produziert fleisch in einer so
einzigartigen umgebung wir müssen uns
gut um unsere wälder kümmern denn das
steigert auch den wert unserer produkte
am ende seien intakter regenwald
schlicht besser fürs geschäft gibt er
uns mit auf den weg dass müssten jetzt
nur noch sein präsident jawoll szenario
und die anderen rinderzüchter begreifen
oft noch mal nach deutschland von der
schweiz bis in den niederlande entlang
des gesamten ryans haben menschen heute
ein zeichen für eine saubere umwelt
gesetzt
mehr als 20.000 menschen sammelten am
ufer schrott und müll mitteilt eile
classic zigaretten ketten insgesamt 170
tonnen so die schätzung der initiative
rhein cleanup nächstes jahr sollen auch
die nebenflüsse gereinigt werden
wettermäßig werden nord und süd deutsche
morgen einen sehr unterschiedlichen tag
erleben denn in der mitte und dem süden
scheint die sonne richtung norden sind
die wolken zunehmend dichter und bringen
etwas regen außerdem kann es dort
stürmisch werden 18 bis 30 grad
auch am montag wird es im süden sonnig
und warm von norden her kommt regen und
es wird deutlich kühler
danach wird es wechselhaft windig und
kühl dazwischen zeigt sich aber auch mal
die sonne viel noch die lotto zu 1 16 24
26 31 34 43 superzahl ist die 7
die angaben sind ohne gewähr weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6 und dann
hat uns eben gerade noch diese nachricht
hier erreichte rudi gutendorf ist
gestorben
die trainer legende die in 55 trainer
statt denn zum anfang und 50
trainerstationen 32 ländern gearbeitet
hat julius buch der rekorde ja das
rekordverdächtig engagiert hat in vielen
entwicklungsländern hat ihn zwei im
zweier bundesverdienstkreuze eingebracht
ein 100 93 jahre alt und im aktuellen
sportstudio gleich mehr dazu von uns
herzlichen dank und bis morgen dann zur
gewohnten zeit um viertel vor zehn bis
dahin
[Musik]